Hello, everyone.
Welcome to my
lecture, The Anatomy
and Physiology
of Thalamus and
Internal Capsule.
In this hour, we're
going to talk about
the growth organization
and connections
of the thalamus,
as well as its
major nuclei and
their functions and
their connections
with other structures,
especially with the
internal capsule.
Internal capsule is
very important with
multiple limbs carrying
different information
uh you know linking
the thalamus and other
structure other body
parts to the brain
we're going to then
talk about the blood
supply of the thalamus
and internal capsule
please pay close
attention this is a
very important lecture
related to a lot
of clinical deficits
and presentations
read the detailed
objectives in the cpg
please and also the
scholar Rx brick.
Looking at the
Comlex blueprint,
we're going to,
you know, see a lot
of sensory disturbances
and pain that's
highly relevant to
thalamus. This is
true for different
types of sensory
modalities like
tactile stimulations,
vibration, temperature,
proprioception,
and especially pain
there are different
kinds of pain that's
highly relevant
to the pain pathway
and thalamus
is one of the
important structure
this is true for the
general sensory system
as well as the
internal cathode itself
same here for the
usmle blueprint you
can see it's related
to general sensory
modalities for
normal processes and
different types of pain
syndromes for abnormal
processes very
important sensory
structure thalamus
is one of the major
structures of diencephalon
you can see here
so on the left this is
orange and the green
you know and the red
these structures are
just from different
angles you can tell
thalamus is buried inside
the brain pretty deep
so thalamus is forming
the third ventricle
wall you can see here
in this 3d model the
two large ventricles
are the you know in
blue color is the lateral
ventricle and then
you have this middle
one in yellow color
that's the third ventricle
the purple one is
the fourth ventricle
so thalamus has this
interthalamic adhesion
that's why it kind of
poking through the
hole of the third
ventricle so the
interthalamic adhesion is also
called ***** intermedia
it connects the two
thalami from the two
hemispheres together
showing here is a
slice of the thalamus
as you can see here
you know the thalamus
can be divided
by these internal
medullary lamina into
different segments.
You can see
here anterior,
medial, and lateral
part of the thalamus.
Each portion has
multiple nuclei that's
carrying different
functions of the thalamus.
And then there is also
this outside lining
of reticular nucleus.
You can see a
bunch of neurons here.
They are carrying the
inhibitory neurotransmitters
that's regulating
the nuclei inside
the thalamus we're
going to talk very
specific relay sensory
information as
well as the motor
information how they
are relayed to different
regions to the brain
to the cortex we're
going to also talk
about the diffused
functions from the
thalamus to the
association cortices as
well as limbic areas.
The inputs to the
cortex from the
thalamus has two
different kinds.
One kind is a
specific information.
You can see here if
we review the anatomy,
this is our central
sulcus and this is the
postcentral gyrus
which is this area and
do you remember what
is the postcentral
gyrus function it's
actually somatosensory
cortex so the somatosensory
sensory cortex
receives information
from the thalamus
specific nuclei so these
are specific pathways
directly to the
somatosensory cortex. And
then there are also
diffused pathways that
send inputs to all
over the brain, all
the different types
of association cortex,
including all those
lobes, frontal lobe,
temporal lobe, parietal
lobe, occipital
lobe. And so all
of those lobes are
receiving diffuse input
from the thalamus.
I'd like to
highlight a crucial
difference in terms
of the ascending
pathways and
descending pathways.
So the major
difference is that the
ascending pathways all
go through thalamus
because thalamus is a
very important gateway,
But the descending
pathways like the
corticospinal tract,
corticobobar tract,
corticopontine tract,
all those tracts
that are trying
to reach the body,
different destinations
of the body,
they do not go
through thalamus.
So this is
very important.
So it does not mean
that none of the
motor functions are
regulated by the
thalamus because
thalamus do communicate
with the basal
ganglion but even
that is actually
ascending pathway.
So the basal ganglion
send information
to the thalamus and
then from thalamus
send it to the cortex.
So those are still
specific pathways
at afferent but for
the efferent like the
corticospinal cortical
bulb are different
types of motor
functions does not
pass through thalamus.
So if you have
any thalamic
vision, you can
imagine for the most
part the movement
is intact.
This is the
horizontal slide of
the thalamus. You can see
clearly this egg
-shaped structure
being differentiated
into the anterior,
medial, and the
lateral portion by the
internal medullary
lamina. And you do need to
know the relative
position of these nucleus
group, but I would
not ask you to really
pinpoint the different
specific nuclei.
There are many nuclei
in the thalamus, as
you can see here, all
color-coded from a
different region, and
there is a long list
of the names, right?
So it looks scary, but
in fact, these names
are very helpful
because they are really
telling or descriptive
about where they are.
You can see here,
you know, for example,
CM central median,
and, you know, VPL
is ventral posterior
lateral, and VPM
ventral posterior medial
right so based on the names
and their abbreviation
you can already
know where these
nuclei are so they're
not as bad as it looks
so we have anterior
nuclei and dorsal
medial and in the lateral
division there are
a few very important
ones, functionally
very important ones,
VA and VL, so ventral
anterior and ventral
lateral, and VP, VP
actually being divided
into VPL and VPM.
So we're going to talk
specific functions
of all of those,
as well as the
provenal. So these
are all the lateral
portions, so VA, VL,
VP, and and popular.
Again, showing here,
you can see VA,
VL, and VPL here
at the lateral
portion of the thalamus.
This is the same
horizontal slice
of the thalamus.
There are two major
types of nuclei
in the thalamus,
and one is relay
nuclei, the other is
association nuclei.
So previously, we
mentioned about two
different kinds of
input from thalamus to
the cortex, right? So
you remember one is
specific input, the
other is more diffuse
and goes to
association cortex. And
so these two types of
nuclei are in charge
of those two different
types of input.
So you can see here
with a specific input,
you know, from the
subcortical size,
like a spinal cord
can be sent to via
specific nuclei. Those
radianucleides are
very specific for
individual functions.
And so it goes to here,
here, and here, you
know, just have three
drawn here. Do you
remember from the anatomy
lab, what are those
three areas that are
receiving specific
input? Do you remember
the functions of those?
And here too,
actually four.
So if you
remembered, this
is our central sulcus,
right? So then what's
the function of
the precentral gyrus,
postcentral gyrus,
the superior temporal
gyrus, and
occipital lobe.
You should still remember
this is for
motor function,
somatosensory,
auditory,
and vision. So
those are the
specific inputs.
And then there
are also
association nuclei.
This association
nuclei actually has
reciprocal connections
with the cortex.
So basically they
send information to
the association
cortex. They also
receive information
from association
cortex. so that's
a two-way traffic.
Those are more diffuse
and higher-order
functions related
to the cognition,
execution of
the behavior,
related to learning
and memory, and also
sleep-wake cycle control.
So the association
nuclei are working
with the large
areas of the cortices,
including frontal,
parietal, occipital,
and our tamper lobe. So
every lobe is involved
with the association
cortex, involved with
those association
nuclei in the thalamus.
Okay, let's look at
some of these relay
nuclei. As we mentioned,
the relay nuclei
meaning to relay specific
sensory information
through specific
nucleus of the thalamus.
So this is the
coronal sections,
you know, a
series of coronal
sections of the thalamus.
These letters A,
VA, VL representing,
you know, A is anterior,
VA is ventral anterior,
VL is ventral lateral.
So these letters
are fairly straightforward
descriptive
of what kind of
nuclei they represent.
Let's start with our
a anterior nucleus.
So anterior nucleus
later on in the limbic
structure lecture,
limbic system, there
are multiple structures
that's linked into
like linked together.
So this anterior
nucleus is one of
the limbic structures
it's actually linking
the hippocampus with
another important
limbic system structure
called cingulate gyrus
and these hippocampus
and mammary body
is linked to the
anterior nucleus of the
thalamus via mammothalamic
tract and so
these are you know
forming that circuit
that are important for
emotional processing
of the information.
Now the VA and VL
a lot of times are
functioning together.
They are critical for
the motor coordination.
So the motor
signals from basal
ganglia as well as from
the cerebellum and
travel through the
thalamus up to our
motor cortex including
the primary motor
cortex premotor cortex
and the supplementary
motor cortex so va
and vl working together
to transmit these
modulatory motor
signals to the cortex
now let's look at look
at VPM and the VPL
together so VPM is
ventral posterior medial
nucleus VPL is a ventral
posterior lateral
nucleus so these two
are for the sensations
of the body and the
face so the VPM you see
a star here actually
has two functions so
it's mediating both the
visceral sensation as
well as somatic
sensation of the face. So
the VPM is mediating
the three cranial nerves
7, 9, and 10 for their
visceral sensation
send the information
to insula
which is a big
visceral cortex.
And on the other
hand, VPM also
mediating somatic
sensation of the
face through the
trigeminal nucleus,
I mean trigeminal
ganglia,
trigeminal nerve
number five.
So trigeminal nerve
send information, you
know, of the somatic
sensation of the
face through VPM to
somatosensory cortex.
so you're going
to learn about the
homunculus of the
sensory function
in the general
sensor systems
and so that's for
the face and then for
the body the vpl ventral
posterior lateral
nucleus will mediate
this dcml and stt
spinal thalamic tract
so it's one for touch
and proper obsession
and then the other
is for pain and
temperature somatic body
sensation also send
the information to
the somatosensory
cortex so there is a
mnemonic to help you
remember these two
so vpm is very pretty
makeup so you can
imagine makeup is for
the face and then vpl
would before the
body somatosensation.
Now another pair,
so MG and LG, the
medial geniculate and
lateral geniculate,
those are two
relatively small bumps
located at the
bottom, so at the
ventral and lateral
aspect of the thalamus.
So if you recall
in our lab four,
medial geniculate
actually located
very close to inferior
colliculi and so
that's to mediate
the auditory
information and send
it to the auditory
cortex at the superior
temporal gyrus.
So midbrain located
very close to the
medial to the to the
temporal lobe and so
the median geniculate
is right next to our
midbrain structure,
inferior colliculi.
And lateral geniculate
transmitting
the vision information
from the optic
tract and then send
it to the visual
cortex located at
the occipital lobe.
And so these two,
how do you remember
which one is for
what? The mnemonic is
about the M is music
and the L is light.
So medial geniculate
for hearing and
lateral geniculate
is for the vision.
So this way you
could remember. So A,
anterior nucleus, is
for our limbic system,
emotional responses
and then VAVL is for
our motor system motor
related modulation
so it's ascending
information for motor
functions and then
VPM and VPL those
are for our sensations
you know for face
versus body and then
mg mediogeniculate
and the lateral
geniculate those
two one for the
auditory information
m is music and
then the other is
for visual
information l is light
and that's all the really
information i'm
going to mention
Here, I hope you
noticed that we have
not mentioned about
DM and pulmonar.
So DM is dorsal
medial nucleus, and
then pulmonar is
another big, very big.
It's actually the
largest nucleus in the
thalamus. So what
are those two for?
I hope you've guessed
it that these two
nuclei are not for
specific relay nuclei,
they're actually
association nuclei
that we're going
to cover next.
Here is a summary
view of all
thalamic nuclei
connections. Here
is a summary of where
things uh you know go
what is the input from
what are the relay
nuclei that are in charge
of those uh information
passing along to
whichever uh cortical
areas that um you know
for the specific relay
for the specific
information so uh you
have to remember all of
these and remember them
accurately so make
sure you go through
these in great details
and remember all of
these relay nuclei what
function they are in
charge of okay so here
you know again I'd like
to add some of those
mnemonics to help you
remember so for
example the VPL
ventroposterolateral
and VPM so those
two structures
are both related to
somatosensory sensation.
The difference
is that VPM
processing the
trigeminal components
or the cranial component
of it. And so you
can remember it by
thinking about VPM is
very pretty makeup.
That's for the face.
And so you would
remember then the other
one, you know, the
counterpart VPL would
be for the body. So
those are the two
different types of
input for somatosensory.
And then there's also
medial geniculate
and lateral geniculate.
So those two are
also, you know, the
little two bumps at the
bottom of the thalamus.
One is for auditory,
the other is for
vision and you can
remember by m can be
equal to music and that's
for hearing and
then l the lateral
geniculate is for light
that's for vision so
those would really
help you differentiate
the two very similar
nuclei that you know
controlling different
functions okay i'd
like to mention that all
of these relay nuclei,
you know, all of these
are thalamocortical
pathways with specific
information has
similar type of circuits.
So you can see here
for auditory function,
right, you start
with auditory receptors
in the cochlea, and
then it sends information
to the brainstem
neurons, then to the
thalamus, mediogeniculate
nucleus, and then
up to the auditory
cortex, right, going
in this direction.
And if you look
at the vision, you
would have the
photoreceptors in the
eye, goes up to the
retinal neurons,
and then lateral
genucleic nucleus in
the thalamus, and
then visual cortex.
So those are very
similar functions that
start with the first
order neurons or the
primary african neurons,
and then pass information
to the secondary
order neurons at the
brainstem and then
or sometimes in the
spinal cord right and
then the third order
neurons is a thalamus
that was a specific nuclei
and then goes to
specific areas in the
neocortex for the
conscious perception so
this is a general
pathway that's a pretty
much fit into all kinds
of sensory functions
Now let's go
through those two
nuclei that we did
not cover previously,
the dorsal medial
and the pavana,
and what exactly
they're doing.
So those two association
nuclei, those are
very, those are not
very specific in terms
of, you know, like what
type of information
it carries. It's a higher
order ceramic nuclei,
basically regulating
something more related
to the higher function,
like cognition,
like planning, you
know, like awake and
sleep cycle. so those
are higher order
functions a lot of
times is to synchronize
the cortex neurons
to functions uh you
know like different
areas of the cortex
function uh so not
like synergistically
to regulate the
function you know to
make our brain more
efficient as you can
see here the dorsal
medial nucleus
actually related to
the prefrontal cortex.
So prefrontal cortex.
And then the
pulmonary, you know,
such a big area,
it also correlate
with a very
big association
cortices. So the P is
parietal, O is occipital,
and T is temporal.
So all of three of
these lobes association
cortex are sending
the information
between POT and Povner.
So remember, these
information are actually
two-way. They are
reciprocal. So the dorsal
medial nucleus sends
the information to
the frontal cortex, and
the prefrontal cortex
also sends information
back to the thalamus.
So these are reciprocal
innovations to
help the thalamus
regulate to the cortex,
and then vice versa.
So this is a higher
order functions for
the association nuclei.
The very special
nucleus in the thalamus
called reticular nucleus.
We mentioned previously
that those reticular
nucleus are located
kind of in the
lateral aspect of the
thalamus, And it's only
inhibitory projections.
And those projections
actually is not
going to the cortex,
but actually coming
back to the adjacent
parts of the thalamus.
This is very important
for directing
attention and sleep
-wakefulness cycles.
We all have the
experience that if you're
concentrating on
something, You know, for
example, now I'm
concentrating on the lecture,
I would not be able to
pay attention to the
outside. You know, if
I have someone knock
on my door, I won't
be able to hear that.
So this type of direct
attention requires some
inhibitory. Like you
have to suppress some
information by
reaching the cortex and
capturing your attention.
Right. And then you
have to let some other
information through.
So basically acting
like a gate. So
selecting specific
types of input
that being perceived
by your brain.
So it's a very
important nucleus,
reticular nucleus
in that regard.
This one, the diagram
just kind of show you
how it works. So
basically we have those
projection neurons from
the thalamus to the
cortex right so this
is a glutamatergic
neurons and then you
have from the cortex from
the cortex all the way
down to the thalamus
those are also positive
you know excitatory
and those two types
of projection neurons
both send the projection
you know collateral
projections to these
reticular nucleus.
And these reticular
nucleus will send
information back to inhibit
specific subpopulation
of the thalamic neurons.
And so this way,
the reticular nucleus
can regulate what
type of thalamic neurons
are activated and
which type of thalamic
neurons are inhibited.
So it acts like a very
important gateway.
Okay, so the thalamic
neurons, those projection
neurons have two
physiological states.
One is called
tonic mode. The
other is called
burst mode.
So the tonic mode,
you can see here, you
know, every single
spikes you know like
one two three four
five those five spikes
are you know the
same exact shape and
you know the distance
between them are also
the same so they're
firing very regularly
and faithfully so
basically you know
carrying the information
consistent way and on
the other hand for
the burst mode you can
see you have two
spikes that's you know
connected together and
then you just don't
have any specs here.
Basically, there is a
refractory period that
there isn't any new
firing of the lamp
neurons can be detected.
So the tonic mode is
considered to relate
specific inputs, and
those are accurate, means
transmitting the
information faithfully.
and the birth mode is
unable to transmit the
information basically
so they're inaccurate
what are the
physiological meaning or
significance of these two
different modes turn out
the birth mode may be
related to the sleep
-wake cycle. So it might
be when the brain is
under the sleeping mode,
you have a lot less
information being
passed on to the brain.
And it might also
underlie some
pathological conditions,
such as epsom
epilepsy, when the
cognition, you know,
when the attention
is not really paying
paid to the to the
outside stimuli.
So this type of a burst
mode is considered
to be due to these
calcium channels
that has a long
refractory period. So
they have a burst
firing. And then after
that firing, they
have that long
refractory period that
does not allow any
new action potentials
to be generated.
And so these are
still under active
research exactly what
the significance of
those. Some considered,
you know, because
of the connections
with the cortex, you
know, very tightly
relationship with the
cortex with all of
these different nuclei,
right, including
the association
nuclei, as well as the
specific nuclei that
are transforming
specific inflammation.
So they may
relate it to the
sleep-wake cycle
regulation or
something like
epilepsy or ADHD.
And there are
some relatively
clear studies
showing that in
this tonic mode
is when people,
you know, during
a wake stage. So a
lot of times when
you record from the
thalamic neurons,
when people are awake,
then you will see those
tonic mode firing for
the most majority of
the thalamic neurons.
And this is when
all of these
ascending reticular
activating system
neurotransmitters
are released.
And so the
brain, you know,
the entire cortex
is activated.
So the ARAS system is
activated
completely to show,
and then when the
thalamic neurons
are showing most
majority tonic
mode, this is during
the wake state.
The sleep, especially
the slow-wave sleep,
much more majority
of the snap
neurons are in the
burst mode. So this
burst mode, as
we talked about,
those calcium channels
are having long
refractory period,
and then the signal
would not be transmitted
to the cortex
facefully. And then,
you know, for the ARAS
system, you also
have like a largely
decreased in all of
these neurotransmitters.
That's related to
awake and arousal.
And then during the REM
sleep, what
would you think?
What do you think
during the REM
sleep, which type
of mode the thalamic
neurons is mostly
recorded at?
The answer is tonic mode.
So this is,
again, remember
the EEG that we recorded.
The EEG during the
REM sleep is most
likely just like
the awake stage,
right? They're
also the beta wave.
However,
the neurotransmitters
here only have
acetylcholine increase
release, but you
have complete shutoff
of the rest of the
neurotransmitters
in the ARAS system.
So basically, this
is a major difference
between the REM sleep
when you have active
dreams and during a
complete awake state
when you are aware of
all the surroundings.
So it's quite
interesting to see these
different patterns of
the thalap neuron firing.
All right, now
let's talk about
the blood supply
to the thalamus.
So there are two
arteries I'd like to
highlight. The posterior
cerebral artery,
PCA, supplies the
most majority of the
thalamus. And then we
have anterior choroidal
artery that's
coming off of either
internal carotid or
middle cerebral artery.
This artery is
important for the blood
supply of the lateral
geniculate body.
So make sure you remember
those two arteries.
that's important
for the thalamus.
Now let's look at some
of the cases clinically.
What do you see here
in this patient?
So my title kind
of gave away which
thalamic lesions that
we can see from these
MRI images, right?
So here's a lesion,
another view,
another view.
So if you remember
our image previously
was showing, so
this is mostly at
a VPL area that
there is a lesion to
the thalamus. And
do you guys remember
what VPL is in a
responsible form?
It's related
to the somatic
sensation, right,
from the body.
So this patient
actually experienced
a parathisia. So the
initial parathisia
and then followed
by alladenia.
Alladenia means the
normally not painful
stimuli. for example,
the touch. So
when you comb your
hair, it does not hurt,
right? When you wear
a shirt, it does
not hurt. But at
the pathological
condition, those can
be hurtful and painful.
So for example, a
classical example of a
sunburn, you would feel
the shirt touching your
shoulder now hurts.
So that's alladenia.
Something like
alladenia could
happen in different
types of stimuli.
You know, for
example, temperature,
it can cause
alladenia as well. So
sometimes, you know,
the normal cool
temperature can be
perceived as painful.
So, and mechanical
also. So those are
the symptoms for
this type of ******
patients. Only about
10% of ****** patients
develop neuropathic
pain so these are
because of the central
nervous system damage
caused pain we call
it neuropathic pain
very hard to treat
these types of pain
another case
shown here please
pause the video and read
let's look at the
MRI and MRA images as
you can tell here
there is a lesion you
know bilateral lesion
of the thalamus
right in the middle
here in the MRI and
then for the MRA you
know you can see the
arrow is pointing
toward this blood vessel
do you see anything
strange about it
As you compare to the
normal people, you
can see, you know,
this is a PCA, right,
posterior cerebral
artery, that has two
branches that's supplying
the two thalami.
And for this variation
of artery of a
percheron, you can see,
you know, out of the
PCA, there's only
one branch supplying
both sides of the
thalami. So here, if this
artery has been
occluded, then you're
going to have a bilateral
thalamus damage.
So this is one of the
important variations
that, you know, really
produce some more
severe consequence
when there's embolism.
Fortunately, when the
embolism is resolved,
usually there is a
pretty good prognosis.
The function can be
recovered
pretty variably.
this is an interesting
clinical case you
can see here focused
ultrasound thalamotomy
meaning using the
ultrasound to lesion
part of the thalamus
you can see here
this is the lesion
area the loci and
then you know you
can see before the
treatment the patients
you know, when you
ask the patient
to draw the spiral
lines, they can't
really do it smoothly.
It's all jagged. And
then after the lesion,
you can see they're
pretty much able to
stop that essential
tremor and be able to
draw these lines
somewhat smoothly, right?
And of course, you
know, the area of this
lesion is actually
very close to our areas
of VAVL. You know,
these are the regions
that's connecting
with our basal ganglia
as well as cerebellum
so these are the
information the sensory
information from the
basal ganglia cerebellum
being sent to the
cortex to help
coordinating movement so
it makes sense that
when we have you know
special like pathology
involved with this
nuclei then the
essential tremor happens
and when that's lesioned
it can be treated
however the side effect
would include you
know that sensory and
gait disturbances right
you know related to the
base of ganglion
cerebellum
here's another
interesting case that
the simulation of
the central thalamus
revives the minimally
conscious patient
showing here with
mri you can see where
the position of the
stimulating electrodes
in the thalamus.
You can see here,
right, the two pretty
big electrodes.
And, you know, this
30-year-old man was
actually comatose. You
can see the Glasgow
Coma Scale is only
three. And so that was
like no response to
any stimuli whatsoever.
So deep coma state.
and after this deep
brain stimulation to
the thalamus almost
immediately it
changes the arousal so
that's the day one
you have these uh
you know rapid bilateral
head turning to
voice and then on
about day 143 the
patient actually can
start using objects
and then by you know
And then 60 days
later, the patient
can start doing rehab.
So this is just like
a miracle response
from this deep brain
stimulation of the
thalamus, indicating
the importance of
the thalamus in
terms of the arousal.
Okay, so that wrapped
up our thalamus section.
Now let's go into
the internal capsule.
So I put the internal
capsule in this lecture.
is not because internal
capsule is part
of the thalamus,
but it does have a
quite important
relationship with the
thalamus. And
also, it sits right
next to the thalamus.
You can see here,
these are our two
bilateral thalamine, and
internal capsule is
living right next to it.
So that's why we put it
together here
to cover both.
There are five
pathways, very important
pathways inside the
internal capsule.
First, let's orient
ourselves. So this is a
horizontal slice of
the thalamus and the
entire brain so this is
our anterior posterior
and so we're kind of
looking down to the
brain and this is one
part you can see our
familiar structure here
is our thalamus and
so the three different
subdivisions anterior
subdivision dorsal
medial nucleus group,
and the lateral. So
those are our thalamic
nuclei. And then you
have the C, which is
caudate, so a caudate
nucleus, and P is putamen.
This is a part of the
lenticular nucleus.
So all of these are
part of, you know, so
caudate and putamen
are called striatum,
and putamen and globus
pallidus is part of
the forming the
lenticular nucleus. You
can see the shape looks
just like the lens,
hence the name
coming from. So these
are the landmarks
that for the internal
capsule. And the
five pathways are,
the first one is
anterior limb of the
internal capsule,
which is here. Internal
capsule is a large
bundle of fibers.
Remember from the
last slide, right?
So these fibers
here, that's in
between the caudate
and putamen.
So kind of forming
a bunch of stripes
cutting through the
caudate putamen. And
that's where the
striatum coming from. So
they're striated by
the internal capsule
anterior limb. And
then we have the second
part called genu. So
genu is right here,
which is like
a turning point
connecting the
anterior limb with the
posterior limb. So
this is our posterior
limb of the
internal capsule.
And so the genu is
like a knee, right?
It means knee. So
it's like a knee
joint in between the
two parts, two limbs
of the internal
capsule. And then we
have the sublenticular
and ritrolenticular.
So basically,
those two parts
are relative to the
lenticular nucleus,
right? The sublenticular
is underneath, so
that's why we don't
really see it here
because it's buried
underneath the lenticular
nucleus. And
ritrolenticular part means
caudal to the
lenticular part, So that
would be this part of
the internal capsule.
And so those
five different
branches have
very specific
information passing
through them.
Do you need to
remember every single
limb? And so make
sure you pay close
attention to this
slide. You need
to remember which
function is being,
you know, mediated
and transmitted
at a different segment
of the internal capsule.
So let's go through
them one by one.
They're all color
-coded here, so you can
see the orange color
here. That's for the
anterior nucleus of
the thalamus. So right
here, remember that
anterior nucleus of
thalamus that's
connecting with the
cingulate gyrus through
the anterior limb of
the internal capsule.
And the anterior limb
of the internal capsule
also carries the
information from the
dorsal medial nucleus
of the thalamus
all the way to the
association cortex at
the prefrontal cortex.
So the anterior limb
has those two functions.
And the posterior
limb has a lot more,
so you can see all
these lines here.
so the blue one is
for the VAVL that's
remember carrying the
motor functions from
the basal ganglia and
cerebellum and then
send them to the
motor cortices and the
other one is you can
see here in green those
are the VPL and VPM
so the VP sections are
carrying the sensory
information to the
somatosensory cortex.
So the posterior limb
of the internal capsule
is super important
because it's
related to both the
descending information
from the motor cortex to
the body, as well as
the ascending from
the body to the
somatosensory cortex. So
this is very commonly
tested in any exams.
And now the
sublenticular and
retrolenticular part of
the internal capsule.
So the both parts
are a lot of times
correlating with the
similar functions together.
So the sublenticular
can carry the
information from the two,
like a medial geniculate
and lateral geniculate
nucleus information
related to the
auditory and vision.
And the Pavanar
is another
large association
nucleus.
Pavanar's information
is also carried by
those two, the
retroverticular and
sublenticular part of
the internal capsule.
Last but not least,
the genu. So the
genu is depicted
here in this light
blue, it's actually
mediating the
corticobulbar
tracks. So the motor
control of the face
or the cranial aspect
is actually mediated,
transmitted with
this genu segment of
the internal capsule.
So again, showing
here to the brainstem,
that's the corticobulbar
tract and to the
corticospinal tract
is going to the spinal
cord and then innervating
the entire body.
So this is a very
important slide.
Remember all those
information is critical.
Showing here again
is just a summary of
the internal capsule
different limbs.
uh what are the
origin what is the
destination and uh you
know other names for
these uh information
like whatever tract
that the information
is passing through
again this is very
important for ******
diagnosis or for the
presentation of the
lesion so whichever
way it goes you need to
remember where exactly
this information
Now, for the
blood supply of
the internal
capsule, these two
arteries are
super important.
Lanticulostriate
artery, remember we
were talking about
the anterior limb
is in between the
two basal ganglion
nuclei, the caudate
amputament, right?
So the lenticulostriate
artery, from the
name of it, you can
imagine this is a
major blood supply to
the striatum and so
the medial cerebral
artery is the main
middle cerebral artery
is the main one that
having this
lenticulostriate arteries
coming off of it and
another very important
artery is anterior
choroidal artery
previously we mentioned
that this artery is
supplying the lateral
geniculate nucleus
of the thalamus, now
it's also important
to supply the
posterior limb of the
internal capsule. So,
both of these arteries
are very, very important
for the internal
capsule. So, you
need to remember
them, especially
lenticulostriate artery.
It's easy to get
the infarct called
lacuna infarct. And
then when that happens,
you have the reduced
function of the
internal capsule.
And then you would
have, you know, the
patient would experience
both the motor and
sensory deficit.
All right, so now
it's really all the
summary slides. You
can test yourself by
filling the blanks
for the thalamus here.
These are the
answers. The
last slide
showing all these
different
nuclei together.
all right that concluded
our lecture thank
you for spending
another hour with me
hopefully that was very
clear if you have any
questions make sure
you email me i will get
back to you if you
have any comments and
suggestions make sure
you use this link to
send me the feedback
Thank you very much.